I have a group of friends right and when  I walk into the room with a group of  friends I know immediately who's going  to get the most attention from the guys  it's it's not me right I have like a  friend who's like very very attractive  and I know when I walk into a room with  her like the guys talk to her first  because like girls you can kind of just  feel it but I almost wonder when I hear  like and I hear this from girls a lot  like I'm a 10 I'm a 10 I'm a 10.  um if that's not like rooted in reality  because attractiveness like there's  numbers behind it whether it's just your  results in the world or your dating app  data or  the like the type of guys you can get